Next game magius 3 from the
USA
obviously people like to play it at night,
although on the west coast it's
just midnight now so
we'll see when we get there position
he plays G6 on it you can now
play comfortably yourself the whole variant
is comfortable for Black
solid like that but now he's playing
pretty badly with tower E8 and E5 the idea
is now to actually play with CD5
and when he
answers CD5 knight B5 okay he's
defended that now I can
make normal moves so somehow
tower D1 or something like that  But it
might be interesting to
take it and try to penetrate C7 directly with rook C1.
It's
not clear which rook I'll take
the
rook, so okay, it has now moved knight F8.
Maybe I want to make knight
E6 possible, but so C7 is
initially as
planned  He could move queen F6 to
perhaps avoid the exchange of queens,
yes, now I have to
think about bishop G7, he has ef3, that
probably won't work, so
I'd rather go to D4,
but I could also swap the queen first.
Ah, I can just see when he then
knights  E6 plays I might have
a problem here with the
B2 knight E6 I could move E3
Structure looks awkward but I
have the cline good I'll swap
the queen first
so what's now bishop F6
bishop F bishop G7 bishop G7 EF bishop
f6a if  He goes to go2 and takes bishop which
has one
quality he could still play rook D6
bishop E7 rook E6 bishop simply
takes F8 yes that's probably a pawn in the end
okay so after ef3 I can of course just
move bishop simply F8 and at the end there should be one
More pawns when jumping out even if there
are unequal bishops but I have the
cline so if he simply takes back
I play knight D4 with a very
comfortable
position,
which
may be able to neutralize relatively quickly
so
okay so now I have to move the bishop
away, of course I would actually like to follow suit
here good first of all first
back here so G2 he can now cover with running H3
but whether that is a good idea
I actually do
n't think so F3 F3 G4 would be my idea and then
King F2
G3
Maximum what he should achieve would be to
swap everything here now  so now let's put
the bishop
better first
H
well, well the bishop so easily
I can't get the
G2 so fights for the
cline yes of course it's kind of a
strange position with the stranded
bishop there on H3 he's of course
never allowed to get on that in any way  first row
maybe the tower C3 is an
idea with the idea really G4 and to
clarify the matter here but well he can of
course always take and play tower F8
so now maybe the idea A5
A4 yes from
him what is it like no that works too
Not a difficult
position at all B4 with the IDE
B5 yes I have to play a little faster
here yes B5 I actually thought
now if he takes rook C7 H7 then
the bishop is really
gone
and the
check is as good as it gets,
of course he gets passed pawns, a pretty
dangerous one I would
say so I have to take
such a figure we have won but whether
that's enough to do something here
is not that easy
so time
warning well I have to get
rid of it probably check
so now let's see that we can get
the tower over quickly
Pawns are very
dangerous.
I also have to look at the way the bishop is
on e5, but it does
n't help to eliminate the
pawns at the
moment
but again an
A3 like that but here too he can't move the pawns
at first
unfortunately I was very slow again
I already know it so unfortunately I didn't
see that
shame
check and 20 seconds left that's very
unpleasant bring the king over
check
check now I have  I only have 12
seconds left so I have to play a little
faster
6 seconds yes my God of course bit
the
position I have no
idea yes now just a yes of course
an absolute joke game that you
can never lose but it's good
if you play so slowlyit
yes what the heck I have to go faster
play